hey guys so recently I had a question
about sleep apnea what causes it and
what can you do about it so this is the
condition which really affects someone's
sleep you see this a lot in diabetics is
there a connection yes there is so when
you have high glucose okay
high blood sugar it depletes vitamin b1
Kevin thiamine because vitamin b1 is
essential and maintaining normal
function of your brainstem especially
the breathing centers which connect to a
nerve called the phrenic nerve which
comes down from the brainstem and goes
right to the diaphragm so the entire
diaphragm the motor control the function
of the movement of the diaphragm is
controlled by this one nerve so if that
nervous cut you're not going to be able
to breathe so what happens this part of
the nervous system is under what's
called autonomic nervous system function
now the autonomic nervous system works
on automatic but you can also influence
it too so right now I can stop reading
if I want and then if I forget to
breathe that autonomic nervous system
will kick in there and breathe for me
when I'm sleeping
that system actually breathes for me so
I don't have to think about it so here's
a thing so when your spouse is let's say
snoring I'll sudden you hear them stop
breathing for a period of time dot sleep
apnea
that's definitely involving these
breathing centers right here so it's
really the the high-sugar okay which
depletes a vitamin b1 which then you
lose the function of the breathing
centers
I'm if you take a look at other symptoms
of low vitamin b1 you have lactic
acidosis that basically the situation
where your pH becomes slightly more
acidic and you'll have problems
breathing just from that alone or
there's another condition called dyspnea
which is basically difficulty breathing
it's related to something called berry
berry what is that that's a vitamin b1
deficiency
but people could have a moderate or a
subclinical deficiency that might not
show up on blood tests but it's just
gradually going into a major deficiency
also there's another condition called
SIDS sudden infant death syndrome okay
where this infant just stops breathing
for no reason well that also is related
to a severe b1 deficiency in an infant
which basically affects the breathing
centers again a lot of information you
can find when you study beriberi or look
at the relationship between vitamin b1
deficiency and SIDS you'll find a lot of
interesting research so that's why it's
very important to make sure that the
infant is breastfed or if you're getting
a formula that it has enough b1 and
other nutrients because some of these
formulas are just pure sugar avoid of a
lot of good nutrition anyway I just
wanted to point out that if you have
sleep apnea you may want to start taking
vitamin b1 and in addition to that take
nutritional yeast because that will also
support and prevent any other
deficiencies from higher levels of Adam
b1 alright thanks for watching
hey so if you haven't done so please
press subscribe now that way you can be
aware of all the new content that I'm
putting out on a regular basis